you're sure it's mine hi everyone my
name is Tamara chambers and this is
Tamara's never seen and today I am
watching mortal kombat I'm gonna be
honest with you all I feel like Street
Fighter and Mortal Kombat are pretty
interchangeable in my mind from what I
remember all I ever did was button mash
with them I don't know is there a story
to Mortal Kombat's like the game Mortal
Kombat honestly the only fighting game
did I ever truly got really into is the
Super Smash Brothers franchise and I
still have my copy from when I was a
child so yeah this is the only fighting
game I didn't button mash with I played
this Kirby so basically cheating I love
video game movies I love them so much
and part of that is loving the cheese
factor cheese factor what a disgusting
way to describe all right cheese factor
aside I'm excited
[Music]
you
but vengeance that's so much simpler why
was this movie this movie did not need
to be as good as it was the characters
were well developed better than Street
Fighter I thought that the pacing was a
little slow the sets were out of this
world and the effects were they weren't
good I'll say that you know what I'll
just there back there but it came out in
1995 it's a different we gotta remember
that at the very top of this film Street
Fighter and Mortal Kombat were kind of
interchangeable for me film wise but as
you get into this the vibe of Mortal
Kombat is so much different than Street
Fighter 20 Fighter
I had a ridiculous silly stupid blast
with mostly because of bison but this
while still having some cheese factor is
cool the vibe is cool
Mortal Kombat is this giant tournament
of fights and if you win ten in a row
you get to overtake whatever planet that
you want so right now earth is in the
balance and so they have to win Mortal
Kombat to save the earth and I love it
and it's silly and it's kind of taking
itself a little too seriously but in the
best way I would look really really
onboard up until they get to this other
realm where Mortal Kombat takes place
and the evil guy who the main fight is
gonna be against he has this like
reptile statue that then comes to life
and when it comes to life he's like yeah
go follow him and keep a lookout on her
blah
you're my little minion reptile statue
but it comes to life and it looks so so
bad like yikes
that is some of the worst worst effects
I've ever seen in my life and they just
they keep coming and then my favorite
character I think would have to be Lou
and he is ah I'm agreeable he's well I
he's he's pretty he's very attractive
you guys alright
it's my type LuAnn and Shia LeBeouf from
even-steven somehow there's a better
introduction of the characters though so
you get to have a backstory for Lou you
get to have a backstory for Sonya you
get you have a backstory for fir'd for
Johnny crunch or whatever his name is
you have a backstory for all of these
characters and there's a lot of them
there's a lot of things going on but
it's not as ridiculously done as it is
in street fighter you get a sense of
everyone it's just fun to watch the sets
are cool
the locations are impressive the
lighting is like dark but still engaging
and interesting you can see things like
done in a creative way that the music is
amazing and the effects are God the
effects are bad so the Mortal Kombat
tournament vegans and Lua has the first
match and he wins and so you get the
first your show he's my fake chocolate
so much fun and I'm like oh yeah I
remember that that's from the game okay
there we go
I did it Sonjia wins her magic she's
such a badass it really really loved her
character from the get-go as it goes
along I don't love her character as much
but we'll get to that why Sonya grew up
then Johnny crutch or whatever his name
is
fights scorpion I don't actually know if
he fought scorpion there was like three
of them there were swarthy and reptile
and sub what's his name he's from the
game I should know this sub-zero sub
subterranean that's a that's a bar and a
music venue at Chicago so it's not that
though this scene is really cool and at
first I really wasn't digging Jonny
crunch what is his name
it's not Jonny I just want to say Johnny
Cash Johnny crumpet
this is the scene that really got me on
his side I loved this unit takes place
in a huge field and I think it's
scorpion he's fighting and he's got the
little dude that comes out of the pan
he's like a Texan it's really cool again
the effects are garbage but the fighting
and the choreo is just so spot-on it's a
really fun scene the sets are nuts the
locations that they got and then he
destroys scorpion in the coolest way
possible there's like a llama but we got
a bit bit like like lava is inside of
this diamond scorpion and then he
explodes I don't know what else do you
want from a film I just don't
if that doesn't satisfy you then I don't
know what you want also there's a fight
scene where a groin shot leaves Goro
completely immobilized for like a whole
minute a giant monster immobilized by
like a fun low groin shot so it's mostly
quality those were $500 glasses asshole
say that every time to my purse when it
claims another pair of my sunglasses but
they were $1.00 I should take better
careful as the film is going on
unfortunately Sonia gets taken by the
main bad guy and acts as our damsel in
distress for the rest of the film and
it's a total bummer she starts off as
like the coolest character and street
fighter there were so much badassery
with women so I wanted Sonia to be that
for mortal combat but alas
so Raiden finally is like there's
nothing left I can teach you and Lou is
like sick then I'm gonna go fight the
guy rains like hell yeah do it in so
many words then in the end he wins and
and the souls are escaping from the bad
guy niggas to see if little brother soul
again is really nice it's a great cap on
that story and and then it's all as well
Lola is that a setup for a second at the
end is there a second one what oh my god
there's a second one as a three
that's a 3% on rod honestly I had such a
good time watching this movie it was a
lot better than I thought it was going
to be and I felt similarly with Street
Fighter but like I said earlier where
Street Fighter was fun and dorky and
cheesy this was and my crazy and sings
it was legitimately like a good video
game movie and my nuts is everyone I
gotta read these pretentious John Bailey
I love you John says best movie score
slash rave party song ever agreed the
music in this was a brilliant oh my god
my ultimate guilty pleasure movie I'm so
proud of you for watching this please
wear sunglasses for the review ah let's
see predictions hmm you wonder why no
one seems to know what a flawless
victory is since every time they say it
it's not flawless yeah absolutely
flawless victory every time you won't
understand why the Highlander is an
Asian god but you'll really like him
anyway oh man I left him in the
Highlander movies Tamra has not seen
Highlander they should be on the list
for some day too
[Laughter]
every person on this piers welding
something right now there will be a
Raiden hairflip Liu Kang is the sexiest
Asian ever I'm just gonna say that just
the sexiest ever hmm people love Johnny
Cage and his name is Johnny Cage I I
grew to love him
I didn't write at the top but but I
definitely grew to love him I don't know
a movie like this doesn't strike me as
the movie that's gonna have really good
character development and it totally did
and I think that's the biggest thing
that I enjoyed from it is that I just
got done watching Street Fighter where I
had very little so it's really nice to
know watch this and be like oh they can
do that why don't they just do that all
the time thank you so much for watching
and blast with this one then we'll see
you all next week
your soul is mine
[Music]
[Applause]
you